This is the brief on session 19,
so the adventures are pretty
desperate right now.
They need to retrieve the body
of their fallen cleric Trexedor
from the town of Valachi, but.
Uh oh.
The town's controlled by the
villainous Lady Fiona Wachter.
Think local tyrant who's also a
cleric of the archdevil
Asmodeus.
The goal?
Resurrection.
But getting there means stealth,
violence, and maybe walking
right into a deadly supernatural
trap.
First, the resurrection plan
comes together.
After learning Trek Seder was
executed and his body's been put
on display.
Grimm, the party that's
Yurihorn, Radley and Dermont
decide they must get him back.
Their hope rests on this figure,
the Abbot of Saint Markovia, who
they recently discovered is
actually a celestial being.
Maybe powerful enough they hope
to raise the dead.
Second the retrieval attempt.
Yeah, it turns into a brutal
ambush.
It's past curfew.
Super dangerous, but they get
help from their where Raven
allies, the Martikoffs.
So Dermont and Radley managed to
trick 4 guards by pretending to
be drunk.
The fight that follows is quick
and lethal.
One guard gets stabbed,
another's battered down hard.
The last two try to make a run
for it, but Yuri Horn's arrows
and Radley's fire bolts stop
them cold.
One guard even burst into
flames.
Pretty intense.
Finally, just as they grabbed a
body, victory turns sour.
Like really fast.
As Radley cuts Track Seder down,
an illusion of Lady Walker
appears, looks real but isn't,
and summons actual devils from
the 9 Hells.
We're talking a big scary barbed
devil and these awful flying
spiny devils.
And here's the bad news.
Radley finds out his fire magic
totally useless against these
things.
He gets hit by Hellfire, grabs
the corpse which is literally
getting jabbed by double spines
as he carries it, and just runs
for it.
Yurihorn joins the retreat,
trying to heal Radley as they
flee towards the Blue Water Inn,
with devils right behind them.
They got the body back, yeah,
but escaping devils from the 9
Hells?
That's their immediate life or
death challenge now.
Welcome back to the Deep Dive.
Today we are really getting into
something heavy, a narrative arc
that honestly represents A
catastrophic, almost fundamental
shift in the campaign we're
following.
We're plunging head first into
session 19.
This is where the adventurers,
well, they stopped facing just
the mundane tyranny of a small
town.
Yeah, it gets worse.
Much worse.
And discovered their enemy has
literal ties to the 9.
Hells yeah.
This is where the stakes stop
being, you know, political
intrigue and just become
infernal.
That's a perfect way to put it.
Our source material details this
spectacular failure, A rescue
mission just completely gone
sideways, right?
And it's immediately followed by
this desperate high risk
retrieval caper, all in the
hostile town of Awlaki.
The environment here is just
thick with like mold fear.
And soon enough.
And soon Brimstone.
Exactly.
So our party Eurohorn the
Beastmaster, Ranger, Radley the
Eldritch Knight, and Dermont the
Arcane Trickster rogue.
They're fugitives now.
They've just fought the town
guard, fought Lady Walker's
wardens, and they lost badly.
Their companion tracks the door
the cleric was left behind.
Captured and, as we find out,
executed.
Their immediate situation is,
well, it's basically untenable.
Tactically, they've hit absolute
rock bottom.
So our mission today in this
deep dive is to follow their
desperate plan.
We're going to unpack 3 phases.
First, there's the nerve racking
bit of just hiding in recovery.
The immediate.
Aftermath.
Second, the critical planning
session with our allies, the
Martakovs, who are absolutely
essential here.
Couldn't do it without them.
And finally, the explosive
ambush which actually sees in
its immediate goal.
It does, yeah, surprisingly.
But it culminates in this
terrifying reveal that
completely redefines who, or
rather what, the enemy actually.
Is it really shifts everything.
What's fascinating here is how
quickly the narrative just zooms
past the standard fantasy
tropes.
You know, the political
plotting.
Right, like dealing with an
oppressive burger mistress that
feels almost manageable in
hindsight.
Exactly.
We shift from that kind of
problem to something far more
ancient, deep, and honestly
cosmically terrifying.
So the initial setting really
hammers home the immediate
danger and how far the
adventures have fallen.
They're literally huddled in the
cellar of this vacant, decrepit
house.
This is where Danica Martikoff
there were Raven Ally basically
stashed them to avoid instant
capture right after their failed
escape attempt.
I think we need to pause on
describing this hiding spot
because it sets such a perfect
atmosphere of just dread and
failure.
Oh, absolutely.
It's not a safe house, not by
any stretch.
It's an absolute mess.
Like properly grim.
Yeah, cluttered with furniture,
draped in cobwebs, piles of old,
maybe rotting clothing,
moldering books, just general
debris everywhere.
It really emphasizes how quickly
these, you know, pretty powerful
adventures were reduced to just
cowering fugitives surrounded by
the junk of lives long gone.
And that neglect kind of mirrors
their own immediate despair,
right?
Totally, And that despair was
probably compounded by their
physical state to Radley
especially.
Right after hours of being
unconscious, their first concern
when they finally come to isn't
even planning the next step.
It's neutralizing the specific,
very oppressive restraints they
put on Radley.
And this detail is so crucial,
isn't it?
Because it says a lot about the
enemy's intelligence network, or
at least their methods.
Exactly.
Radley wasn't just tied up with
ropes or something simple.
Oh no.
The authorities fitted him with
heavy manacles.
An iron mask.
And a gag.
These weren't just general
restraints to stop him fighting
back.
That gag feels very specific.
It was specifically to prevent
him from casting spells.
Verbal components, right?
So they knew or suspected
strongly.
It implies the town guard, or
maybe washers.
People knew they were dealing
with some kind of spellcaster,
maybe even recognize the signs
of an Eldritch knight.
They didn't just want him
contained, they wanted him
tactically neutralized.
Which forces the party right
then and there to rely totally
on Derman's specific skill set.
An Eldritch Knight like Radley
is usually the armored
frontliner, relying on strength
and steel, but in that moment
completely helpless.
They're wholly dependent on the
finesse of the Arcane Trickster
Dermont.
He had to use his skills, not
just picking locks but doing it
in the dark under who knows how
much pressure.
Probably shaking, I imagine.
Probably to free Radley from
that incredibly restrictive iron
setup.
It's a great little illustration
of how every class role is just
essential when things get this
desperate.
OK, so dermone gets some free.
What's the next immediate move?
Well, once freed, their first
instinct is naturally light.
They need to see.
So Radley, reclaiming a tiny bit
of his power, his identity, uses
magic.
He casts a light spell onto a
small stone.
Simple enough magic, but.
But this simple act immediately
highlights just how precarious
their position is.
Because any light is basically a
beacon saying here we are
exactly, visibility is a death
sentence.
They instantly realized.
That tiny bit of magical light
has to be covered up, shielded
somehow, even a faint glow
filtering up through the
floorboards or maybe through a
grimy basement window.
Would instantly give them away
to the search parties.
They know we're patrolling
outside.
Who are undoubtedly looking for
any anomaly, any sign of life in
supposedly vacant buildings.
It's that irony again, isn't it?
Magic.
Their strength is also a massive
liability.
No, totally.
The light might chase away the
rats and spiders in the cellar,
but the real danger, the human
danger outside, that remains
paramount.
They're trapped, basically
waiting for nightfall,
absolutely unable to risk the
streets.
So they wait, and the tension
must be building from just
sitting there doing nothing.
Right, and you're a horn.
The Beastmaster.
He gets restless.
Maybe after the ordeal, maybe
just his nature, He uses the
time to search the cellar.
Looking for anything useful,
weapons, food.
Probably finds nothing of value,
apparently, but his searching
stirs up this thick cloud of
dust and mold again, just
emphasizing the decay of this
place.
But more importantly, his poking
around reveals A sealed trap
door at the back of the cellar.
A.
Possible way out or in?
Well, it shakes their focus.
They managed to pry it open and
climb up into the house above
ground.
They scout the rooms quickly.
What do they find?
Main floor is sparsely
furnished, everything covered in
shrouds confirms the place is
truly vacant.
But just as they're maybe trying
to get their bearings, no, the
outside world reminds them,
they're very much being hunted.
The near miss.
Tell us about that.
A search party sounds like it's
led by a vigilant guard, passes
right outside.
They're being thorough, banging
on doors, shouting, checking
houses.
Standard procedure for a
lockdown I guess.
Yep, and they reached the house
the adventurers are in.
They rattled the front door,
checking the lock, testing it.
And Radley's still holding the
light stone.
He.
Is.
And this is where quick thinking
saves them.
Radley instantly claps his hands
over the stone, just completely
snuffing the visible light.
Wow, that close.
That quick reaction is
absolutely the difference
between survival and, well,
immediate capture and probably
execution right there.
It confirms everything.
Danica warned them about being
seen in town before dark.
Yeah, not an option.
It's a death sentence.
Absolutely.
So after that incredibly tense
few moments, heartbeats pounding
probably as the searchers move
on down the street, the choice
is obvious.
Back to the seller.
Immediately retreat back to the
perceived security of the
decrepit seller.
Lilo confirms that for now, the
only winning move is just to
wait it out.
Hashtag, hashtag be the
Martikoff connection and the
fatal news.
The narrative really emphasizes
just how slowly that time
passes.
It must have felt like an
eternity just waiting in the
dark and the damn.
Oh, absolutely agonizing.
They don't dare move until the
very small hours of the morning.
You know, when the streets are
absolutely at their quietest.
I said they finally emerge.
Yeah, they come out from the
bulkhead entrance to the cellar,
probably navigating around the
debris Danica had left there for
cover, and they make their way
quickly and stealthily through
the back streets.
Heading for the one place they
trust.
The single point of relative
safety they know the blue water
in.
And this is where that alliance
with the Martikoffs, the whole
Brotherhood of the Feather
connection, really pays off big
time.
Immensely, they find both Danica
and Irwin Martikoff waiting for
them in human form.
The source notes the genuine
relief on Danica's face when
they stumble in.
That must have felt good for a
second at least.
For a second, Irwin immediately
secures the door behind them,
gets them inside properly and
they're given essentials.
Cold meat, cheese, bread.
A simple but desperately needed
meal after everything they've
been through.
But that moment of relief, it
doesn't last, does it?
Not at all.
It's shattered almost
immediately.
There's really no time for
sentimentality here.
Danica, always pragmatic, just
delivers the news.
Crushing news.
Traxidor.
Traxidor is dead, executed by
the Burga mistress Lady Walker,
shortly after their failed
rescue attempts.
They were too late.
Oh that's brutal, especially
after they risked everything to
go back for him and the detail
about the body.
Yeah, that's key.
His body wasn't just, you know,
disposed of quietly.
It's been publicly hung in the
streets.
Not just retribution then it's a
statement.
It's a profound act of public
desecration designed to
demoralize everyone, terrify the
populace, and send a very clear
message to any other potential
troublemakers like them.
So this moves the whole
situation from just a tactical
failure.
To a moral imperative.
They're exhausted, they're
wounded, grieving, but they just
cannot leave their friends
corpse hanging there like a
public spectacle.
Right.
So after maybe getting a little
rest until late morning, the
mission completely pivots,
doesn't it?
Fundamentally, it's no longer a
rescue.
It's now this elaborate,
incredibly high risk retrieval
caper, a body snatch.
And Derman and Radley, they
immediately fixate on one
frankly audacious goal.
Getting Tracidor's body to the
Abbot at the Abbey of Saint
Marcovia.
Why?
What are they hoping for?
They need to find out if the
Abbot actually possesses the
power to raise tracidor from the
dead resurrection.
OK, so deciding to risk
immediate recapture, certain
death, probably just for a
corpse that requires some
serious justification.
Enormous justification.
You have to imagine.
The Martikoffs, even though
they're supportive allies, must
have been deeply skeptical of
such a frankly suicidal plan,
right?
Like you want to do what now?
Exactly.
The justification lies entirely
in their previous encounter with
the Abbot in that memory.
Let's dig into that memory then,
because like you said, it's the
only thing driving this
seemingly insane plan.
They recall for your horn, who
maybe wasn't there for the key
reveal.
But the Abbot isn't just some
powerful local clear he had
previously revealed himself.
As a celestial being, an Angel.
An Angel during a past exchange
involving their other slain
companion, the paladin Surin
Ironwood.
And that specific detail that
he's a celestial is absolutely
vital here, isn't?
It it's everything in a domain
of dread, like Borovia, which is
explicitly designed as a prison
plane where hope is
systematically crushed.
Yeah.
The presence of a true celestial
being is incredibly rare and
potentially incredibly powerful.
It suggests that the really high
level, difficult resurrection
magic stuff that's typically way
beyond the reach of mortal
clerics might actually be
possible available via the
Abbot.
So it's the ultimate long shot,
the ultimate risk reward
calculation.
Totally.
They have this circumstantial
evidence, this one encounter
that suggests this Abbot can do
something genuinely miraculous.
And if tracks the door, their
dedicated cleric, Their healer.
If you can be brought back.
The party is restored back to
full strength, full
effectiveness, which they
desperately need.
And there's that other
connection too, isn't there?
The original reason they were
even in Valaki.
Right, you have to connect those
dots.
The whole reason they came to
Valaki in the 1st place was to
complete a mission for the
Abbot.
Finding a wedding dress, wasn't
it?
Finding a specific wedding
dress.
It was a favor they were doing
for him.
Now they're essentially planning
to turn up on his doorstep with
a corpse and well collect on
that cosmic debt, so to speak.
The risk involved is just
immense though, Stealing a body
that's being publicly displayed
as a warning and having to
somehow crash through a heavily
defended town gate that's
basically an open declaration of
war against the burger mistress.
It absolutely is, yet because
the potential reward is the
intervention of a celestial
being, a genuine Angel to
resurrect their friend, they
deem the cost necessary.
It completely overrides tactical
common sense survival instinct
almost.
It really speaks to the weight
of their loss, how much Tracidor
meant to them, but also the
sheer strategic necessity of
having a dedicated healer and
divine caster in their group.
Resurrecting Tracidor isn't just
emotional for them, it's a
critical strategic need.
Hashtag, hashtag be gear, allies
and historical weight.
OK, So the decision is made.
You're going for it.
And the Marticus, seeing their
determination, fully commit to
helping.
Yep, their alliance, defined by
the secrecy and frankly, the
efficiency of the Brotherhood of
the Feather, transitions
instantly into providing crucial
logistical support.
First things first, they need
Intel, right?
What are they up against?
Exactly, 1st order of business
is intelligence gathering.
Danica immediately starts
coordinating using the
Brotherhood's network.
They need to know the state of
the town gates, their planned
exit.
Points and the news isn't good,
I take it.
Sobering is the word used.
All the town gates are heavily
manned, each one secured with
two or three guards and a
warden.
Lady Watchers Elite.
So no easy way out, no soft
target, no forgotten back gate.
None.
Their plan to just crash a gate
is going to be met with
immediate, probably overwhelming
resistance.
They know that going in.
So since they have to wait for
the deepest cover of night
anyway, they use the rest of the
day to prepare, right?
The Mardikov has arranged for a
cart to carry the body, a
critical piece of equipment
they'll need after they secure
Tracidor's corpse.
They plan to retrieve it later,
but we really need to address
Radley's personal preparation
here.
Because he lost everything when
he was captured, didn't he?
Armor wet.
Free thing, so Danica provides
him with essential replacements.
1st a suit of studded leather
armor, crucial for an Eldritch
Knight who needs mobility but
also protection and a shield.
But this shield is special,
isn't?
It it is, it bears a specific
Raven Crest.
Danica explains that this
symbol, this heraldry, is a mark
of alliance.
It identifies the bearer to the
Brotherhood of the Feather.
So it's more than just defense.
It's a subtle but potentially
powerful narrative device.
In a town where they are
fugitives haunted by the
authorities, this shield could
instantly identify Radley as an
ally to anyone secretly working
with the Marta coughs.
Like a secret handshake put on a
shield.
Exactly.
It's a tool for social
navigation, for signaling
loyalty, disguises ordinary
military gear.
Very clever.
Danica also offers him a weapon,
right?
A short sword.
She does, but this leads to a
really cool character moment
that highlights Radley's unique
abilities as an Eldritch Knight.
He actually declines the mundane
weapon.
He just thrusts out his empty
hand and his own long sword.
His favorite weapon, the one he
lost, it just appears in his
grip, materializes out of thin
air.
Whoa.
OK, that's useful.
It's a signature ability the
bond and Eldritch Knight has
with their chosen weapon is so
deep it actually transcends
physical separation.
The Burgo Mistress's Wardens
could strip him of his armor,
his pack, everything.
But they couldn't break that
metaphysical bond with his
sword.
Exactly.
It's a nice moment of subtle
empowerment for him, especially
after the complete humiliation
of being captured and masked.
Meanwhile, you're a horn, the
beast master.
He also contributes something
important tactically, doesn't
he?
Reminds them about his healing.
Yes, that's a crucial piece of
information they might have
forgotten in the chaos.
He reminds Dermont specifically
that he can cast healing magic.
It might be a lesser used
ability for a Ranger, a Marshall
character.
But with Traxador gone, their
main healer.
It's suddenly vital.
Any healing is vital.
And he backs this up by
transferring a very specific,
very valuable resource, the
potion.
The potion of greater healing
that was given to him earlier by
the Monster Hunter Rudolf Van
Richten.
He passes it to Dermont for
safekeeping.
That feels like planning for the
worst explicitly.
It is.
They're acknowledging that this
is going to be violence.
Someone will get hurt, probably
badly.
They need immediate, powerful
healing on hand, and they have
to rely on these limited
resources that aren't easily
replaceable.
And before they actually head
out, there's a moment of
reflection about the location
itself.
Yeah, specifically about the
setting for the upcoming action.
Radley may be thinking about the
risks.
Reflects on the really dark
history of the execution square
where Tracidor now hangs.
Or near it, anyway.
Right, this isn't just some
random spot.
No, it's become a focal point
for Valaki's recent brutal
history, Radley recalls.
The execution that happened just
eight days before this.
Their elf companion.
The apparition of their elf
companion Vallanaire appearing
there, followed by Vallanaire's
actual heading the very next day
right in that main square, and
then just days after that, the
public hanging of the former
Baron Vargas Volakovic in the
same area.
So it's just steeped in
violence, a lineage of public
death.
Exactly the recurring use of
this specific area.
Even though tracidor is hung in
the smallest square just
opposite the main grounds, it
confirms this place as a
monument to oppression, to
bloody rapid political change.
It's cursed ground, basically.
And that leads Dierman to wonder
why the smaller square?
Right, that's his initial
puzzle.
If the goal is maximum public
terror and display, why not use
the main, most visible square?
It feels.
Slightly off.
Suggests maybe the new Bergam
mistress Lady Watcher might have
a specific tactical reason for
that placement.
A reason we are about to find
out is far, far more sinister
than just simple public display
or convenience.
OK, so night falls deep night.
The party moves out.
Yep, the corpse is where they
expected, displayed in that
small square, illuminated only
faintly by the moon, hoisted up
off the ground by the noose.
Grim scene and guards 4
centuries stationed around the
body, observing the strict
curfew.
Probably bored, cold, not
expecting anything.
Perfect targets for a bit of
misdirection, then.
Exactly.
Deramon, the master of
deception, immediately comes up
with the plan.
Exploit that boredom, that
complacency.
The core gambit is simple.
Use deception to create an
opening for a swift,
overwhelming blitz.
How do they do it?
Deramon and Radley will pretend
to be drunk.
They'll just stumble across the
square, making a bit of noise,
hoping to catch the guards off
balance.
Betting on the guards arrogance,
they'll just see a couple of
drunken locals breaking curfew.
Precisely assume they're just
useless townspeople.
Easy pickings, not highly
skilled, utterly desperate
fugitives on a mission.
In Eurohorn.
Eurohorn and his Panther
companion take up the critical
supporting role.
They get into position on the
nearby rooftops to provide
ranged cover with his bow.
So.
The plan relies on what stealth
to get into position.
And then absolute brutal
efficiency once the fight starts
and no hesitation.
OK, so Derman and Bradley put
the plan into action.
They stagger out, maybe slurring
insults, making just enough
noise.
And it works.
The guards probably delighted at
the break in monotony, shout at
them, start moving in.
They anticipate an easy arrest.
Maybe you're roughing them up a
bit, confiscating valuables.
Hashtag Tech Tech Tag B The
swift and brutal fight.
But they're very, very wrong.
Oh yeah, The tactical success
hinges entirely on that first
blow, hitting hard and fast, and
Dermont delivers it with
shocking, lethal precision.
How so?
The first guard basically never
even registers the threat.
Dermont moves in close, maybe
looking pathetic, then executes
him instantly.
A clean, lethal strike, the
source says.
Blade up through the belly and
into the heart.
Just.
Wow, cold efficiency that
immediately eliminates one
threat and the possibility of
him raising an alarm.
He then signals to the other
guards and to Radley that this
is not a brawl, this is an
assassination.
Radley immediately coordinates
bringing his summoned long sword
up against a second guard,
instantly putting him on the
defensive.
And you're a horn from the roof.
Arrows start raining down.
The coordinated assault is just
overwhelming.
The remaining 2 guards realize
in a split second that they are
facing something way beyond
drunk townsfolk.
They panic.
They try to run.
Break and flee in separate
directions, desperate to get
away.
Raise the alarm.
And here we see just how high
the stakes are, how much
pressure the adventurers are
under because they don't let
them go.
No mercy shown.
They absolutely cannot afford
witnesses.
Silence is their only chance of
getting that body out of Valaki
unseen.
So how do they stop the runners?
Your horn takes care of one with
his bow.
Another clean kill from range.
Impressive shooting in the dark
and Radley Radley demonstrates
the full brutal power of the
Eldritch Night Fire magic.
He unleashes a powerful fire
bolt spell at the final fleeing
guard.
The source describes the guard
just erupting in flames,
staggering frantically for a few
steps before collapsing into
essentially ash and embers.
OK, that's spectacular violence,
but effective.
Extremely effective, it clears
the square instantly.
In maybe less than a minute
they've eliminated 4 trained
guards.
They have, yes, committed murder
multiple times over in the
streets of Awlaki.
But they've secured their
immediate objective.
The square is clear.
Right.
They turn toward Tracidor's
corpse, finally believing the
hardest part.
The tactical fight with the
Mortal Guards is over.
They just need to cut him down
and get to the cart.
But it's never that simple and
Barovia is it?
Never.
Just as they approach the
corpse, ready to Cut the Rope,
that moment of grim triumph just
dissolves into profound dread.
What happens?
They hear laughter.
Cruel, booming laughter.
But it's not normal.
It's not the sound of a human
woman laughing nearby.
It's unnaturally amplified,
echoed, going across the
otherwise silent square,
chilling.
And they see her.
They turn, and standing just
feet away, seemingly alone, is
the Burgo Mistress herself.
Lady watched her.
Standing there after they just
killed four of her guards.
Apparently, and she immediately
launches into this contemptuous
taunt, calling them inept fools,
claiming their retrieval attempt
was laughably predictable.
Her voice still has that weird
amplified quality, ringing with
this cruel confidence that is
deeply unnerving.
OK, something's very wrong here.
Dermont recognizes the immediate
danger, the sheer wrongness of
it.
He rushes at her sword, ready
for a sweeping strike.
Your horn may be thinking
faster, or just reacting.
Loses errors at her from the
rooftop.
Both attacks pass straight
through her harmlessly, like
she's smoke.
An illusion.
And this is where Dermont's
Arcane Trickster senses his
understanding of basic magic
pays off.
He instantly realizes the figure
is an illusion, a magical
projection.
OK, but he also realizes the
incredibly sinister implication
that comes with it.
The real Burgo mistress must be
nearby, close enough to control
the spell.
Watch them, mock them.
From a position of absolute
untraceable safety.
Exactly, it's pure psychological
warfare taunting them while
being completely untouchable.
So this tells us 2 huge things.
One Walker knew they were
coming.
This is maybe even a trap.
Seems likely, doesn't it?
And two, she has sufficient
magical prowess to project a
convincing illusion and keep
herself hidden.
The illusion isn't a distraction
from her location.
It's a placeholder.
It's a placeholder for what she
is about to unleash.
Hashtag tech tag B.
The summoning of the nine hills.
And this is the moment the pivot
point you mentioned earlier.
This is it.
The moment the campaign shifts
gears entirely, immediately
after the illusion taunts them,
maybe even while it's still
speaking.
Dermont observes these weird
disturbances in the air around
where the illusion stood.
Disturbances like what?
Not smoke, not magical energy
flares.
The source describes them
vividly as like the rippling of
water, like looking through heat
haze, but more substantial
disturbances indicating
something is pushing through a
barrier between planes.
Oh no.
And from these rippling points,
creatures begin to emerge.
This is the moment the threat
level just skyrockets.
Past Valaki town guards, Past
wolves and zombies, Past
anything they've likely faced
before.
OK, describe these creatures.
What comes out first?
1st we see these smaller things,
Heffling sized, maybe flapping
on leathery bat like wings, and
they're emitting this terrible
high pitched wailing screech.
Nasty.
What are they?
The source explicitly identifies
them as spiny devils.
Lesser devils, sure, but devils
nonetheless.
Terrible, but clearly
subordinate to what comes next.
Because there's something else.
Oh.
Yeah, the true horror steps
through the main portal, the
biggest ripple right where a
washers illusion had just been
standing and laughing.
It is a man sized creature, the
Barb Devil.
We need details.
What does this thing look like?
It's a creature that just
screams violence and malice and
has this thick prehensile tail
whipping behind it and wicked
sharp barbs protrude
aggressively from its head, its
back, its arms, its legs,
everywhere.
Sounds painful just to look at.
Its eyes are described as
jaundiced yellow, burning with
the slow, malevolent inner
light.
And it doesn't roar.
It makes this low, harsh
croaking sound, like rocks
grinding together.
But the sensory details that
absolutely cements its infernal
origin beyond just the look of
it is the atmosphere it brings
with it, the smell.
It doesn't just look evil, it
feels evil and it smells evil.
It emanates this foul miasma
that spreads instantly across
the square.
The smell is described as a
supernatural stench of
pestilence, decay, sickness.
Heavily tinged with.
Brimstone, Sulfur.
You can smell the 9 Hells right
there in that town square.
OK, that detail is everything,
isn't it?
Brimstone, The classic sign.
It's the quintessential sign of
infernal origin that sulfur
stench confirms beyond any
shadow of a doubt.
These are not weird magical
beasts or undead.
They are friends, devils from
the Nine Hills.
Which leads to the definitive,
terrifying revelation that the
source material drops right
here.
Yep, these creatures are
summoned devils and Lady Wokter
isn't just a power hungry tyrant
using guards and politics.
She's a cleric of Asmodeus.
A cleric of Asmodeus, Lord of
the 9 Hells.
This means she is actively,
knowingly leveraging the power
of an Arch Devil to enforce her
political will right here in
Valachi.
That completely reframes the
entire power structure of the
town, maybe the whole domain.
This isn't just a political.
She pulled off.
It's backed by a contract with
literal Hell.
Watcher has essentially
installed Infernal Creatures as
her private law enforcement in
the middle of this otherwise
mundane, albeit oppressed town.
It's a frightening display of
how deep the corruption can run
in a place like Barovia and her
laughter.
Her contemptuous, amplified
laughter apparently resumes as
the devils immediately square
up, ready to attack the
adventurers.
The trap is sprung.
Hashtag tag Tag C The chaos and
desperate retreat.
So how does the fight go?
Or does it?
The Devil's waste absolutely
zero time.
The Barbed Devil, clearly the
main threat, immediately
conjures this devastating sphere
of Hellfire.
It's slams into Dermont,
scorching him badly.
He leaps away, already seriously
wounded.
Ouch.
And the little ones, the spiny
devils.
They swarm into the air, losing
these clouds of small, red hot
darts from their tails.
They target both Dermont and
Radley.
It's immediate, overwhelming
offense.
Radley tries to fight back with
his fire magic.
In a panic, yeah, he tries to
counter the threat with his go
to magic, his fire bolt.
He manages to hit one of the
flying spiny devils, but the
result is instantaneous and just
devastating to their morale.
What happens?
He realizes instantly his fire
magic is useless.
Worse than useless, these
creatures are natives of the 9
Hells, a burning hellscape.
Right.
Fire doesn't bother them much.
They probably just laugh it off,
metaphorically speaking.
His simple fire spell does next
to nothing.
This is a critical tactical
failure born of panic and
instinct.
Radley has just confirmed his
primary ranged attack option is
utterly ineffective against this
new terrifying enemy.
OK, so they're facing
overwhelming new threats.
Daremones badly hurt.
Radley's main magic is useless.
This isn't a fight they can.
Win.
Not even close.
The realization hits them hard
and fast.
The combination of the new
threat level and the immediate
ineffectiveness of their magic
forces an instantaneous shift.
Forget fighting, it's time to
run flight over fight.
Your horn sees this chaos
unfolding.
Yeah, your horn, maybe, having
stayed back a bit or just
reacting quicker, guides his
Panther down from the rooftops.
He doesn't charge in.
He starts to flee along a side
street, firing arrows back at a
pursuing spiny devil even as the
Panther sprints away.
Tactical retreat.
But Radley, he's still got the
mission objective in mind.
Radley remains focused even in
the chaos.
He knows this is it, their only
chance to get the body.
He ignores the devils for a
second, rushes to the post where
tracks the door hangs.
Cuts the rope.
Uses a sore, cleaves the rope.
The clerics corpse drops heavily
to the ground.
He doesn't hesitate, he throws
the body, which must be awkward,
heavy, stiff, horrible, over his
shoulder and just runs for his
life, following your horn.
And the pursuit is immediate, I
assume.
Immediate and horrifying, this
is where the narrative really
drills down into the just the
grimness and the emotional
stakes.
The spiny devils loose more of
those red hot darts.
At Radley.
They miss hitting Radley
directly, but the barbs stick
into the flesh of the corpse
he's carrying.
Oh God, that's vile.
It's a deeply morbid detail,
isn't it?
The desecration of Trxador's
body even as they're trying to
save it.
Pure psychological terror from
the devils.
And the big one, the Barb devil.
Relentless hits Radley again
with another ball of Hellfire,
compounding his injuries.
He's staggering, but still
running.
The chase is just this
desperate, chaotic flight down
the dark streets, focused
entirely on keeping hold of the
body and staying alive.
You're a horn still providing
cover fire though.
He is the steady hand.
Even in retreat, he manages to
hit one of the pursuing spiny
devils with an arrow, and this
time it works.
It erupts spectacularly in
embers and just falls to the
street, leaving nothing but ash
behind.
OK, so they can be killed, just
not easily and not with fire.
Exactly.
A physical force works.
That's crucial information.
Maybe for later.
He then catches up to Derriman,
who is already putting their
emergency plan into action.
The potion.
Derriman is literally pouring
the potion of greater healing,
the Precious One from Van
Richten, down the wounded
Radley's throat as they run.
Followed up Eurohorn's own
magic.
Eurohorn immediately casts Cure
Wounds on Radley, apparently
while riding alongside him on
the Panther.
Impressive coordination under
fire.
That teamwork is flawless,
though, focused entirely on
keeping Radley, the guy carrying
the objective, mobile and alive,
trading resources using those
less conventional healing
powers.
Absolutely.
They're burning through precious
resources, but it's keeping them
going.
But the session, the source
material here, ends on this note
of deep, chilling uncertainty.
They're heading for the Blue
Water Inn, right?
They're refugees.
They are.
They're only known safe haven,
the location of their allies,
the Martikoffs.
But the terrible realization is
sinking in even as they run.
The devil saw them.
They know where they're going.
The devils, and by extension
Lady Water, almost certainly
know their destinations, so just
reaching the inn, well, it's
unlikely to provide true lasting
refuge anymore.
Oh man, the infernal pursuit
means they're safe harbor.
The Blue Water Inn has just
become the likely next target.
They might be leading hell right
to the Martikoff's doorstep.
Wow.
OK, so this deep dive, this
session 19, it's provided
several critical pieces of
knowledge that just
fundamentally change the outlook
for the adventurers and frankly
maybe change our understanding
of the nature of this entire
domain.
Absolutely.
I mean the key piece of
information in the bombshell is
confirming Lady Watchers true
nature, right?
She is not just some ambitious
political rival using mortal
thugs and spies.
She is a cleric of Asmodeus,
actively, openly utilizing
summoned devils from the 9 Hells
as her private enforcement.
That's a terrifying escalation.
It means every action she takes
now could potentially be backed
by infernal power.
Exactly.
And on the flip side, on the
side of their allies, the
Brotherhood of the Feather, led
by the Martakoffs, they've
proven to be an absolutely
essential lifeline.
Providing shelter.
Critical intelligence gear.
Yeah, like Radley's Raven
crested Shield, which isn't just
armor now, it's this beacon of
their alliance, a potential way
to find other hidden friends.
And we also saw the vital maybe
sometimes overlooks utility of
each adventurer when pushed to
the absolute limit.
For sure.
Derman's lethal precision and
his lock picking getting them
out of that initial jam.
Bradley's unique bond with his
weapons saving him from being
completely disarmed by the
guards.
In your horn, his overlooked
healing capacity, his range to
combat effectiveness proving
absolutely essential during that
chaotic escape.
They needed every single skill
they had and the confrontation
itself, it just completely
transformed the narrative,
didn't it?
From what seemed like a
manageable, if risky stealth
heist against mortal guards.
Into a desperate, fiery flight
from organized infernal forces.
Actual devils.
The stakes are now cosmic.
They've literally put themselves
in the crosshairs of the 9 LS,
or at least an agent thereof.
So thinking about the bigger
picture here, this revelation,
it raises a really important,
deeply troubling question for
you, the listener, to ponder.
OK, if the burger mistress of
Awlaki, A relatively significant
tone, is openly using summoned
devils as her private police
force, what does that imply
about the true power structure
of this entire domain they're
trapped in?
Is this just her local
operation, or is this kind of
infernal dealing happening
elsewhere?
Is Esmodeus's influence more
widespread?
We don't know.
And maybe even more immediately
worrying, given that the Devil's
almost certainly know the
Martikoff's Inn is their
destination, Can the blue water
in the place that symbolize
their last best hope, their only
refuge?
Can it ever truly be considered
safe again?
That's a truly chilling thought.
It leaves the Marta cops, the
very people who just gave them
refuge and aid in an immediate,
potentially lethal infernal
peril, just for helping.
Them.
Yeah, the consequences ripple
outwards.
OK, that's all the time we have
for this deep dive into the
heart of Awlaki's escalating and
now infernal darkness.
We'll see you next time.
Welcome back.
Today we're looking at some
really intense session notes.
It's the aftermath of a failed
execution rescue in Valaki.
The party's trying to get their
companion Traxador's body back
and they end up fighting devils
summoned by Lady Walker.
It's quite the scene.
Yeah, high drama, Lots
happening.
So where should we start?
OK, let's jump right into the
first point, focusing on the
emotional core.
As I read it, the drive to get
Traxador's body feels very
strategic, like it's mostly
about getting him to the Abbot
for resurrection.
Exactly.
And you know, while that's
logical for the plot, it feels
like we might be skipping a
beat.
Does rushing to the fix, the
resurrection undercut the sheer
weight of their failure?
The actual loss.
That's the heart of it.
So, critique 1.
While the urgency of the
situation retrieving Trxador's
body to be resurrected by the
Abbot is clear, pausing to
deepen the emotional investment
of the characters could
significantly elevate the stakes
of the mission.
Right.
The weakness here is how fast it
moves from shock to solution,
Donica says Trxador's dead boom
and almost the next breath is
well.
The notes say Dharman and Radley
are pondering if the Abbot can
raise him.
It's efficient.
Maybe too efficient?
Yeah, it kind of short circuits
the grief, doesn't it?
The hope of resurrection pops up
so fast it drains that immediate
raw feeling of failure.
It makes the retrieval feel a
bit transactional, like an
objective marker rather than
this desperate act of loyalty.
And we definitely don't want
that.
This is a huge moment.
So the suggestion is to really
lean into that downtime at the
Blue Water Inn.
They're safe for a moment, but
they're broken.
Use that space to show us the
psychological fallout.
Absolutely.
Show, don't just tell, they
pondered.
Let's see that internal
struggle, you know, make them
grapple with the cost.
Is this even possible?
We just failed spectacularly
trying to save him.
Maybe show Radley, specifically
Derman, just risked everything
to free him?
Does Radley feel guilty, or is
he just fiercely determined?
Now let's see that before they
ask Danica to scout.
That pause makes the later risks
feel earned.
That emotional grounding changes
everything.
It turns it from logistics into
like, sheer desperation.
And we can layer that.
What about emphasizing where the
body is hung in that smaller
square?
Dermont's puzzled by the
location, right?
That's a perfect hook.
Oh yeah, a chance to reflect,
maybe connect it to other losses
in Balaki, Valloneer, Vargas.
Exactly.
Tie it into the town's whole
awful cycle of violence.
Suddenly getting Traxador back
isn't just about him, it's about
defying Valaki itself, defying
the despair that really amps up
their motivation.
OK.
I like that.
It gives the mission much deeper
roots.
They're not just fetching a
body, they're fighting back
against the town's very full.
So, moving from the why to the
how, let's talk about pacing and
structure.
The notes cover their escape
after the failed rescue and then
the setup for getting the body
back at night, but the focus
feels uneven.
Interesting.
Yeah, I see that.
It feels like some parts get
lingered on while other high
tension moments are maybe rushed
through.
So .2, the opening sequence in
the dilapidated cellar, contains
details that detract from the
overall pacing, while later high
tension sequences that follow
the escape from the inn are
rushed, diminishing the sense of
danger.
Right.
The weakness is where the
narrative camera focuses right
after the chaos at the gallows.
They're hiding.
The tension should be sky high.
But then we get quite a bit of
detail about Erie Horn.
Searching old furniture,
mouldering books, finding
nothing.
Yeah, and the lock picking on
Radley's restraint, it's very
granular.
Exactly.
It feels like we're getting
bogged down in inventory
management when we should be
feeling their fear, listening
for footsteps outside.
It just kind of slows down that
frantic recovery beat.
OK, so the suggestion cut back
hard on that stuff.
Pretty much compress the non
essential descriptions, focus
instead on what they're feeling,
the fear, the adrenaline crash,
and definitely focus on the
sounds outside the threat.
And then flip side, maybe expand
the bits that are tense like the
actual sneaking around later.
Yes, let's take that seller
search instead of listing dusty
items.
Maybe it's just a quick nervous
action.
Or cut it, but definitely
amplify that moment when the
search party rattles the door.
Yeah, the bit where Radley
covers the light spell.
That's it.
That's pure tension.
Focus on that specific sharp
action.
It instantly reminds us they're
trapped, haunted.
That's way more effective than
describing mold.
OK, got it.
Less inventory, more immediate
danger.
And then apply that detail when
they actually leave the inn
later.
Exactly.
Day 15 Instead of just saying
they pushed through debris,
Danica piled up.
Describe it.
What does it sound like?
Scraping wood?
Heavy breathing in the silence.
Make that escape feel difficult
and risky.
The sound of moving that
bulkhead could echo instantly,
setting the mood for the whole
night operation.
It underlines the curfew, the
danger before any devil show up.
That small bit of sensory detail
totally changes the atmosphere.
It's not just they left, it's
they risked everything just to
get out the door.
OK, that makes sense.
Sharpen the focus, basically.
Good.
So that brings us to the climax,
right?
The Square.
The Devil's Lady Walker.
Yeah, the big confrontation,
this is peak desperation, and
it's good.
But I think we can push the
horror aspect even further, make
it truly unsettling.
Right, it's Borovia.
It should be unsettling, but the
notes seem to jump to the
mechanics pretty fast, like
resistances and immunities.
That's the potential issue, so
Critique 3, the final
confrontation with Lady Walker's
Summon Devils, is excellent, but
shifting the focus from the
creatures mechanical immunities
to the raw supernatural horror
they inflict would maximize the
dramatic impact of the climax.
OK.
So the weakness is that
Analytical Jump devils appear
and Bam Darman figures out the
illusion.
Radley tests his fire spell and
notes it's ineffective.
Which is useful game info, sure,
but in the narrative it pulls us
out of the sheer terror.
It shifts from what are those
things to OK fire resistance
noted.
Yeah, it feels a bit like
reading a stat block instead of
experiencing the fight.
So the suggestion is delay that
analysis.
Dwell on the sensory horror
first.
What does it feel like, sound
like, even smell like?
To face these things, especially
that barbed devil, make the
dread feel physical, alien.
Make it about the feeling of
fighting something infernal, not
just the tactics.
How do we do that?
Well, concrete examples.
The notes mention a foul miasma.
Let's really expand on that.
Make it oppressive.
Does it sting their eyes?
Burn their lungs?
Make it hard to breathe?
Hard to concentrate.
The air itself is hostile.
Maybe Radley tries the fire
spell, and while he's choking on
brimstone, he realizes it did
nothing.
The environment reinforces the
horror.
OK, yeah, layer the sensory
details onto the actions.
I like that.
And what about the body itself
during the fight?
Ah yes, that detail about tracks
of Doors corpse taking the hits,
That's gold.
Radley has spared their barbs as
their spines miss him and stick
into the flesh of the corpse he
carries.
That's incredibly grim and
powerful.
It's perfect for the tone, so
slow, that moment down.
Focus on the sound, that awful
thud or squelch of spines
hitting dead flesh.
Focus on Radley's reaction, the
horror, the grim realization his
dead friend is literally
shielding him.
Oh man, yeah, that makes it so
much more desperate.
It's not just carrying a body,
it's carrying this.
This macabre shield made of
sacrifice.
Exactly that image, combined
with the stench, the struggle
that tells the story of what
this retrieval cost them.
It hammers home the horror and
their desperate commitment.
Right, OK, that really lands the
climax in a much more visceral
place.
So wrapping up, we've hit three
key areas.
This is strong stuff already,
but these tweaks could really
push it over the top.
Agreed.
So first point was about the
emotional core really digging
into the grief before the
solution.
Don't rush past the impact of
Tracidor's death.
Use that downtime to show their
resolve, their desperation that
justifies the risks they take.
Yep.
Second, structure and pacing cut
the clutter and low tension
moments like the seller
inventory beef up the
description and sensory details
during high tension transitions
like sneaking out of the inn
make the act of moving feel
dangerous.
And 3rd, the climax.
Lean into the sensory horror of
the Devil's Delay.
The mechanical analysis.
Use the environment, the miosma,
the sounds, and really maximize
that incredibly dark, potent
image of Tracidor's corpse
acting as a shield.
Make the reader feel the dread.
Absolutely focus on the feeling,
the sounds, the smells, the
sheer awfulness of it.
Implement those changes deep in
the emotion, sharpen the pacing,
focus, amplify the sensory
horror, and this already
dramatic sequence will hit even
harder.
It'll make the retrieval feel
incredibly earned and costly.
Exactly, we think these
adjustments will really elevate
the material.
Feel free to work on these
suggestions and definitely send
it back our way when you're
ready for another look.
Welcome to the debate.
We're diving back into Valaki
today, looking at those really
tense moments right after Lady
Watch to seize control.
Specifically, we're focused on
that mission by Yuri, Horn,
Radley and Dermont.
You know, when they tried to get
Traxadora's body back.
Now, Lady Walker clearly
expected them.
She set quite the scene.
So the big question for us,
pulling directly from what
happened that night, is really
about her intent.
Was this whole set up, choosing
that specific spot the the
taunting with the illusion,
bringing in those devils, was it
fundamentally a cold, calculated
tactical maneuver to wipe out
these fugitives?
Or was it primarily A
performative act, a way to
really hammer home her spiritual
authority as a cleric of
Asthmadeus?
My view, I lean towards the
tactical objective being the
main thing here.
See, I disagree with putting
tactical first there.
I think to really get Walker's
actions, you've got to look
bigger picture beyond just this
one fight.
Think about the display she
created.
Her whole rise to power was
marked by public violence.
Remember, Volunteer?
Remember the former Baron Vargas
Volakovic?
Both hanged publicly.
This showdown with the
fugitives, I believe, was
staged.
It was like a ritual to
reinforce her dominance after
all that turmoil.
So I'm arguing that her actions
were fundamentally driven by
this need for a very public,
very dramatic performance of
her, well, her fiendish
authority.
Sure, getting rid of the
adventures was probably
something she wanted, but I
think it was secondary to just
making this grand statement
about her power, her role as the
the spiritual fist of the
Nouvellaki.
OK, I understand the context,
the political backdrop, but for
me, the evidence for careful
clinical preparation is just,
well, it's undeniable.
Lady Walker didn't just luck
into this, the text explicitly
says she was ready for it.
Even called their attempt
laughably predictable.
Now that doesn't sound like
someone just setting up a stage
play, does it?
That's the language of a
planner, someone setting an
ambush.
And if your main goal is
elimination, then efficiency,
controlling the terrain, those
are crucial.
Think about it.
The fugitives had tangled with
guards before in the main town
square, right?
Very public, very political
space.
But Wachter specifically put
Trexidor's body in this small
square, which is opposite the
execution site.
That feels like a very
deliberate tactical move.
It diverts them to ground.
She controls ground optimized
for an ambush, keeps them away
from, you know, potential crowds
or wider guard involvement.
And then look at how she
ambushed them immediately
summoning devils, A barbed
devil, spiny devils.
That's overwhelming force.
Lethal force.
It screams elimination,
finality, not just trying to
scare them off.
But isn't the nature of that
force the very thing that points
to performance?
You call it lethal, efficient,
and OK, it is lethal, but it's
explicitly fiendish.
Lady Walker is a cleric of
Asthmadeus, right?
And when that barbed devil
showed up, it wasn't just some
monster it brought.
And I quote the supernatural
stench of pestilence tinged with
brimstone.
That's not just hiring some
effective muscle, that's a
direct manifestation of the 9
Hells She's publicly cementing
her connection, her allegiance.
She's basically telling
everyone, defy me and you're
defying Asmodeus himself.
That takes fear beyond just, you
know, getting arrested.
It makes it about eternal
damnation, and that requires
spectacle.
The whole thing starts with
spectacle, doesn't it?
The illusion, the voice,
unnaturally amplified, echoing
everywhere.
Her contemptuously berating them
as inept fools.
That's pure theater, pure
psychological warfare.
It reinforces the idea that she
doesn't just control the guards,
she controls reality itself.
The location, the corpse, it's
all part of this grand public
story she's telling.
OK, let's push on the tactical
staging a bit more, because I
think that's where the
performance idea starts to fray.
If her main goal was
performative, you know, making a
big symbolic impact for the
whole town, why not use the
mainstage, the town square?
That's the center of power where
the other hangings happened.
Why confuse your targets by
putting the body somewhere
secondary?
And why do it at night during
curfew?
That minimizes the audience,
doesn't it?
If the show is the main weapon,
she kind of while she ditched
most of her audience.
I'm not sure she did ditch her
audience.
Maybe the audience wasn't meant
to be the whole town peering out
their windows.
Maybe the primary audience was
the fugitives themselves, and
through them any other hidden
rebels.
The strangeness of the small
square location could actually
serve the performative goal.
It shows her power isn't just
tied to the official spots like
the gallows.
It's everywhere.
Death can find you anywhere she
wants it to.
And you know the small square
with streets converging.
It might offer a more dramatic
visual frame for that single
hanging body, a symbol of death
that feels more pervasive, maybe
because it's outside the usual
political stage.
If it were just a
straightforward trap, wouldn't
the setup have been clearer,
more direct, less room for
confusion?
See, I think you're maybe
overthinking the symbolism
there.
That ambiguity, that confusion,
that is the tactical advantage.
It isolates the target.
It minimizes Walker's own risk.
The small square was an
efficient kill zone, perfect for
a quick, devastating hit.
Remember, the adventurers were
already sneaking around after
curfew.
Drawing them somewhere
secondary, somewhere less
obviously guarded, meant they
wouldn't attract attention until
it was too late.
And the fact that the initial
guards those 4 centuries were,
quote, easily overcome by the
drunken ruse?
That's a key tactical element.
Walker probably expected them to
get past the first line, making
them feel secure right before
the real trap sprung, putting
this in the main square that
would have needed a lot more
visible security, potentially
tipping them off or just causing
a bigger mess.
The small square delivered high
lethality with low initial
setup, letting the devil's pop
in right on top of them and see
aimed at elimination.
OK but if efficiency was truly
the name of the game, why bother
with the illusion at all?
If the plan is just devils
appear, kill everyone, the
illusion seems like, well, an
unnecessary flourish, doesn't
it?
A waste of time and maybe
magical resources.
I don't think it was a waste.
I think it was a primer, A
psychological trigger perfectly
timed for deploying the main
weapons.
The illusion.
It only lasted a moment, right?
Just long enough to stun them,
misdirect them.
Think about how it played out.
The booming voice taunts.
Derman charges in, thinking he's
hitting Wachter, and poof,
nothing.
That split second of shock, of
realizing it's fake, That's the
window.
That's the time bod for the
rippling portals to open up
those creatures.
The devil's.
They needed a moment to
materialize, right?
The illusion was essentially
covering fire.
It occupied the adventurers
attention just long enough for
the real threat to deploy
without being immediately
targeted while they were
forming.
I'd frame that differently.
I think the psychological impact
was the main point.
The illusion set the stage,
sure, but the taunting, The
voice booming with cruel
laughter that continued even
after the visual trick failed.
Right as the portals opened,
Watcher wasn't just creating
tactical cover, she was rubbing
their noses in it, asserting her
total dominance, her superior
knowledge, right up to the
moment of violence.
She wanted them to feel
humiliated, manipulated, utterly
scorned by this distant cleric
pulling the strings.
The spectacle wasn't just cover
for the portals, it was designed
to break them mentally before
the physical attack even
started.
The spectacle was a weapon, and
the devils were just the, you
know, the enforcement mechanism
for that message.
OK, well, if we're assessing the
trap, whether it's performative
or tactical, we have to look at
the outcome, right?
If this was this brilliant
tactical trap designed purely to
eliminate the fugitives, why did
they actually managed to get
Traxador's body back?
Radley cuts the rope, grabs the
corpse, and they managed to
retreat.
He even uses the body as a
shield against the Spiny Devils,
using the very symbol of
Walker's supposed victory
against her forces.
Doesn't retrieving the body
suggest the trap wasn't,
tactically speaking, completely
successful?
I don't think retrieving the
body means it was a tactical
failure.
I'd argue elimination was
prioritized over keeping the
corpse.
And while yeah, they got away
with the body, the trap was
still incredibly successful in
its broader tactical aims.
The barbed Devil immediately
went after Damron and Radley
with Hellfire, causing massive
damage.
The Devil's didn't just give up,
they chased them relentlessly.
And this is the key part.
They drove them towards a
compromised location.
They forced them back towards
the blue water end, which was
supposed to be their safe house.
Exactly.
And forcing their hand like that
had huge tactical ripple
effects.
Urihorn had to burn through
critical limited resources.
Not just his own healing spells,
but that potion of greater
healing from Van Richten that
confirms the trap inflicted
serious intended damage.
It was designed to leave them
crippled, vulnerable.
So yes, they escaped
technically, but they were
forced to reveal their safe
house, use up their best
healing, and basically run for
their lives.
That sounds like a strategic
wind to me.
Even if they managed to carry
the corpse out, the operation
achieved threat neutralization
by making them wounded, exposed,
and ineffective, at least for
the moment.
But what enabled that
neutralization?
It was the display of power.
Yes, the damage was tactically
useful, but I still think it was
secondary to the statement
Walker was making.
She used a public, ritualistic
form of violence, the hanging,
as the bait.
She chose summoned friends when
she could have just used more
town guards.
Why?
Because devils aren't just
fighters, they are living proof
of her unholy power, shown off
publicly to reinforce the
message.
Challenge me, you challenge hell
itself.
The success wasn't measured by
whether they kept the corpse,
but whether the living were
utterly crushed in spirit,
forced to flee in terror from
this manifestation of a dark
magic.
Look, the new regime needs
control.
Control demands stamping out
dissent.
The fact that she ambushed them
precisely when they were most
vulnerable at night, focused on
getting a body not fighting,
that shows cold calculation.
It was about hitting a known
threat group hard, when they
least expected that level of
force.
The brimstone, the booming voice
that was just window dressing,
adding fear factor to an
operation that was fundamentally
about efficient elimination.
And yet, that same window
dressing works perfectly to
solidify her political grip on
Valaki.
After the chaos of the recent
hangings, she needed a powerful,
undeniable show of force.
This encounter tells any would
be rebels that fighting back
isn't just risky, it's
cosmically stupid.
Using her cleric powers to
summon devils in the town square
or near it.
That's political theater
designed to establish a
terrifying new status quo.
The tactical result was achieved
through the ritualistic
summoning.
So to wrap up my position, while
Lady Walker definitely used
spectacle, I believe a primary
goal here was operational
neutralized the known immediate
threat.
These fugitives represented the
the fact that she anticipated
their move, used diversionary
tactics with the location, and
deployed overwhelming targeted
lethal force.
It all points to a sophisticated
tactical operation aimed
squarely at elimination, even if
it was dressed up in fiendish
theatrics.
And I'll stand by the idea that
the whole confrontation was
fundamentally framed by these
displays of immense spiritual,
almost ritualistic authority.
The careful choice of where to
hang the body, the over the top
taunting, summoning actual
devils as proof of her power as
an Asmodean cleric.
For me, all of this points to
the overarching purpose being
performative control.
She was stamping her spiritual
dominance onto Valaki.
Defeating the adventurers
tactically was certainly a
bonus, maybe even expected, but
it served that larger
performance.
It really seems the specific
details we have, the the
confusion over the location, the
exact timing of that illusion,
the Hellfire.
They show this complex mix,
don't they?
The very real security needs of
a new, shaky regime tangled up
with the leaders, deep spiritual
commitments.
It feels like walked around a
suit that in a place like
Valaki, sometimes the smartest
tactical move requires the
biggest, scariest show.
A show which, importantly, also
broadcast the source of her
power.
So we're left asking, does she
rule through Hell's military
might, or does the military
action just serve to confirm the
power of the dark God she
represents?
Definitely more to unpack there
and how she manages to blend
those two things.